let's talk about the movie it's in I
love dogs I love dogs that you voice a
bohemian mountain dog yes sir yes who
the voice did you study dogs at all when
you knew that you were gonna play the
part of a bohemian mountain dog did you
did you try and get into the part of the
dog or no what are you doing what do you
you can't help it you're mad at me yeah
no no no no I have a dog I you know know
everything about that dog not really but
I want to yeah I love you smell the dog
what are you doing oh I sure do yeah oh
we get close and the dog is so good with
children you know now my job my Charlie
ocean jumps on it and loves it up and
how old is 27 sing go two and a half to
half Charlie oceans two and a half but
loves that dog yeah who's telling him
that wave or that's all I did
oh the and and the dog lets him do
anything you know but the dog is lovely
anyway yeah I you know I bond with the
dog I thought about the dog when doing
this part no I didn't even know I was a
bohemian mountain dog before I read the
production notes after the fact
you're saying you phoned it in well you
know the truth is you know I've not been
on the publicity tour with the great
cast wait till you see the to numerous
to mention mmm spectacular West Anderson
cast Wes Anderson a genius he's made a
masterpiece on the foot we I did this on
the phone oh you were on the phone yes
in a he invited me to be with Bill
Murray and Bob Balaban and Edward Norton
and Liev Schreiber and Bryan Cranston
because we were pack of dogs but I
couldn't go for one scheduling reason
others so I stayed here in Californian
West was on the phone and that's how I
did the part that's so cool
you think so yeah I do I think it's
amazing cuz I you're very good in the
part and so it's amazing to me that you
did that over the phone that's all his
doing he knows what he's doing yes yes
yes he knows what he's doing
this is not the standard showbusiness oh
it's not me false humility right he
knows what he's doing okay somebody
hypnotized me bad nineteen forty Sigma
test I you know what I say to Charlie
ocean I say you will gaze into my
peepers gaze into my peepers I say that
Charlie ocean you know what he does what
that's why you're not playing with my
kids near those kids alright let's see
we have a clip here from Isle of Dogs do
we need to you want to say anything
before this clip I've said too much
already what a confection what a delight
take a look at this dogs you heard the
rumor right about Kobayashi
pharmaceutical they invented dog flu
no of course where do you get all these
rumors I mean who tells them to you I
don't know anybody dogs talk and I
listen I always have
I love gossip
everyone knows it too the minute they
hear you
you